good afternoon thank you for coming
today ron has set up
I very interested in storms of various
kinds and I specialize in tropical
cyclones New England's a great place to
be if you're a storm lover for the
reasons that Iran gave where we live in
an area of exceptional temperature
contrast you know in the winter you go
600 miles to the northwest you're in the
Deep Freeze of the Canadian Shield 600
miles to the southeast year in balmy
Bermuda those temperature contrast or
what make winter storms and give us a
stormy climate it might be great if
you're a weather lover it's not so great
if you're insured and insurer and I
don't think it's an accident that a lot
of insurance company at the united
states got their start in new england
and a lot of them are still
headquartered here so of course
naturally it's interesting to ask the
question what's going to happen to these
areas storms as the climate changes we
know to some extent the answers for
certain kinds of storms and we don't
unfortunately yet know the answers for
other kinds of storms I'm going to try
to give you a quick summary of how that
goes well winter storms are a big
concern all of you experienced those you
know what they do to the region
economically schools closed businesses
closed this is a region that this is a
phenomenon that we don't actually
understand well in terms of climate
change there are arguments that you can
make scientifically why these might
become more of a threat there are also
arguments equally plausible why they may
become less and and so we're not in a
good position to know but as Ron Smith
told you in general we expect
precipitation in New England whether
it's rain or snow to increase in the
winter so it's not entirely paradoxical
wouldn't be paradoxical if we saw an
increase in the snowfall in spite of
warmer temperatures another phenomenon
of interest to many parts the United
States even here in New England our
severe thunderstorms an attendant
phenomena like tornadoes even have been
tornadoes here or near new haven it's
not as much of a problem of course New
England as it
is in the Midwest but it is an
occasional problem and hailstorms now
you don't hear very much about hail
storms but unless you're in the
insurance business and that then you
hear a lot about that may all causes
enormous amount of damage the United
States every year and Senator Murphy
told you quite correctly and
interestingly that that weather
phenomena in general and climate
oscillations can have big influence on
political developments so hail plays a
role here to for example there's an
argument to be made that the proximate
cause of the French Revolution was a
pair of hail storms that devastated the
wheat crop in France the summer before
the revolution of course it had deeper
political roots than that but but a
starving population is a pretty good
recipe for revolution so we worry about
that but we don't know very much at this
moment about how this phenomenon severe
thunderstorms hail storms and tornadoes
might respond to climate change it's a
something we're all working on as a
community but the only honest thing to
tell you right now is we really don't
know how these storms might change now
to get to something that we have worked
a bit more zhan hurricanes now I'm
talking to you in a few days on the 21st
of sep tember will mark the 75th
anniversary of the great New England
hurricane of 1938 there a few people
around to remember this not too many
left this was an absolutely devastating
event for New England it killed more
than 600 people now in those days in
1938 we had a far less efficient Weather
Service and the 1938 storm arrived in
New England with absolutely no warning
whatsoever something that's unimaginable
today so there have been improvements
along those lines this is the track this
shows you the track of the New England
hurricane with dates in September so it
started as many do off the coast of
Africa the colors show you a measure of
the intensity so red is saffir-simpson
category 5 so it's marching along at a
nice stately pace
on the twentieth of September off of the
north coast of Florida on 21st and look
what happens in one day it shot up from
off of Florida into Vermont okay hit New
England without warning on the 21st and
cause really absolutely staggering
devastation this is what downtown
providence rhode island's looked like in
the midst of the hurricane you don't
have to have a lot of imagination to
think well you know if that could happen
in 1930 it could happen today you can
see how much water was in the city this
is all the storm surge from Narragansett
Bay that flooded the city of Providence
it happened at least twice before that
we know about in 1815 Providence was
completely flooded by Hurricane and also
in 1635 New England has had three really
catastrophic hurricanes in its history
and some fairly notable ones most
recently of course sandy this is what
the south coast of Long Island looked at
like a few days after the 1938 hurricane
these are all the remains of big
mansions and if you were to fly a small
airplane over that region today of
course you'd see that they'd all been
built back and more so we're simply set
ourselves up for that happen this would
be a problem i would say for New England
and in fact for most of the United
States whether the climate changes
they're not we're kind of under prepared
for this kind of catastrophe now in the
case of hurricanes we've started to
learn how to use physics to get a grasp
on how these storms might change as a
climate change my group at MIT kind of
specializes in this and one of our
approaches is to generate from the
output of climate models thousands and
thousands actually tens of thousands of
artificial hurricanes if you will here
is an example whoops I've gone ahead
here gone far enough here's an example
of hurricanes downscaled not from a
climate model but from a from an actual
observed climate data set colors are a
measure of the intensity you can see the
tracks most of you are familiar with in
the Atlantic here are the storms that
influence the western Pacific
region southern hemisphere and so on and
we can filter those tracks to look at
particular places like here in New Haven
we can look at ten ten thousand tracks
or so storms that affect this region of
Connecticut and we can look at all kinds
of quantities not just wind but rain and
as Ron mentioned and which was certainly
true in the nineteen thirty-eight
hurricane rains a big problem you don't
have to think back very far to Irene to
understand the problems that freshwater
flooding pose for New England here is
one of these synthetic tracks and the
contouring here shows you the
accumulated rainfall in millimeters over
the life of the storm a lot of the big
storms in New England like the 38 storm
are moving very fast so it doesn't rain
very long but nevertheless you get
rather spectacular rainfall totals and
some of these events so we can look at
not just how wind changes but rain and
storm surges so we use these synthetic
hurricanes to we couple them to
something called a hydrodynamic surge
model shows you the grids of two such
models superimposed looking at the
region around Manhattan in New York we
can drive tens of thousands of surge
events and start to look at their
statistics this is from a paper we
published somewhat prophetically about
six months before sandy showing the
return periods sort of a measure of the
frequency of storm surges at the battery
in New York of this magnitude and this
is the return period in years so we
would have said that a magnitude of
three meters which is what sandy surge
was might occur every seven hundred
years so one thing we would say about
sandy is either we were just very
unlucky we happen to see a once in seven
hundred year event which is entirely
possible or the climate may have changed
in some ways to make those storms more
likely we don't know which of those two
is the case but we can run this sort of
downscaling on climate model projections
for future climates and you don't need
to worry about these hieroglyphics here
these are just
the names of five different climate
models that we used to do this we
compared the historical period 1952 2005
with the same scenario that Ron Smith
was telling you about RCP 8.5 and here
is the return periods according to one
of these models for the peak wind within
100 kilometers of where you're sitting
right now New Haven that's about 60
miles or so and these are the return
periods for the current climate
estimated from this model these are the
return periods from the future climate
and you can see in general they go down
which means that the frequency of events
of different magnitudes goes up so a
storm of 80 knots of wind might have
occurred every few thousand years six or
seven thousand years in the current
climate might occur every nine hundred
years or so in the future clam that's
one model of course when you look at
different models you get different
answers and that's a reflection of how
uncertain this business still is we can
still do the same thing for storm surges
at New York this is looking at four
different climate models the black is
the current climate the red and blue are
projections of future climates and in
all four cases because we've also
included one meter projected sea-level
rise which is Ron Smith mentioned even
without changes and storms would
contribute to larger storm surges we get
big increases unfortunately in the
frequency of big surges as well in
hurricane so let me try to wrap things
up climate modeling does show increased
risk for strong hurricanes heavier
hurricane related rain falling storm
surges made worse by rising sea level
not as much as known unfortunately about
the risks of other phenomenon such as
blizzards which are a big deal in New
England severe thunderstorms tornadoes
and hail etc i'll leave you with those
thoughts thank you
you